in the place known as Montana's Paradise
Valley a project resurrected production
on the film rust is restarting 18 months
after Helena Hutchins was shot dead on a
set hundreds of miles from here as the
film's star Alec Baldwin did final
rehearsals he was told involuntary
manslaughter charges against him in
connection with hutchin's death had been
dropped Alec Baldwin and other members
of the cast and crew of rust were doing
last minute preparations here when news
came through that those charges which
were filed in New Mexico had been
dropped a preliminary trial was due to
starting just two weeks time so this was
an incredibly dramatic intervention
and for those preparing to resume
filming a note of relief so Alec is a
consummate professional and I think we
had every confidence in his ability to
act within the movie regardless of
what's going on in any aspect of his
personal life I would say probably
um for everyone else it's a good outcome
in the sense that we feel that justice
has been served
the top of the Spire of a church is all
that's visible of Yellowstone film Ranch
from the public Road
a poignant reminder that it was while
rehearsing a scene in a church that
Helena Hutchins was shot dead the bullet
lodged in the shoulder of the film's
director Joel Souza a year and a half
later he returned to the set alongside
other members of the original cast and
crew
as part of a wrongful death settlement
Helena Hutchins widower Matthew Hutchins
has become an executive producer on Rust
filming in this remote part of Montana
is expected to last just over three
weeks but opinion is divided on the
decision to complete production Molina a
lot of people as you know look at the
completion of this film and view it as
disrespectful insulting even to Helena's
memory I know that you feel differently
to that so we've had a lot of
conversations about this and because her
husband and family are on board with the
production and her husband Matthew
Hutchins is an executive producer on
this film we are convinced that we are
doing what she wanted what her family
wants and we're not really concerned
about the broader public and for
Helena's art not to be seen I think
would be a much bigger disrespect there
are still at least five outstanding
civil lawsuits against Baldwin and the
other producers of rust but the
Hollywood veteran will now finish this
film an actor and not a criminal
defendant